i think the challenge that happens with
god with people
about 12 years ago i started adding one
thing to my affirmation list and it was
stop trying to be god that job's already
taken you're not gonna let somebody else
do that you don't need to do that i
think too often
man uh uh and woman
we try to
act like god to force our philosophies
upon others and i think taxation is
force i don't think it's choice
and it drives a lot of the inner
innovators insane when it's not by
choice
you know you know they asked jesus about
that
in the bible so they said
because there was a debate
at that time and they they went to jesus
and they said jesus help us solve this
debate because you have half the people
saying taxation is theft taxation is
force which i think is what you believe
i think by force it is yes i do
and then on the other side
they were like well you know it's really
bad if we don't pay taxes because look
at what happens and so there was a group
of people called the zealots who were
basically saying don't pay taxes they
were trying to get everyone to not pay
taxes i don't think we don't pay tax
just so you know i'm not yeah yeah i
know i know he's a third i'm a third i'm
a third is where i'm at just so you know
so jesus said well
let me see that coin that you have
your money
who's on it you know what they said
caesar i've heard this a million times
yep
and
so the the idea that we have a financial
system
is something that is owned and protected
by the common good so we've gone to war
for it i i don't i don't defend us going
to war for it in in every circumstance
obviously
and that's a whole other topic that i
you know
don't like war in general but
you know people have been drafted in our
history
and then also if you look at you know
what happened with
native americans when we came here if
you look at you know the history of
slavery and how we got it's really hard
with all of that context to think oh
this money all belongs to me and i
should be able to keep how much i want
because i know the history of how how
this became the way it is and i think
the responsibility that's there
is to do things like pay high taxes
so that that money can go back to making
some of those injustices trying to right
some of those wrongs and i can't we
can't look we can't go back and change
what you live through as a kid right now
we can't but what we can do is we can
create
hopefully a future
where fewer people will will be exposed
to that because that is that's
heartbreaking that you went through that
if we did an audit on your money last
year what percentage your money was
given to charity
oh i i i think charities like uh
especially on the top end is kind of a
a pr scam for billionaires
no no i'm not talking about billy i'm
talking about you specifically i'm
talking about like you how proportion
did you give to charity or or how much
money did you contribute with time and
money last year 2020. oh i'm i'm not i
i'm not i i don't want to sign up for an
audit with you i might i mean i might
like do that if i thought about it the
only reason i'm asking that question is
because yeah typically the people that
impose being the most noble don't do a
lot of it themselves and and that is a
form of judgment and what i mean by
judgment by that is let the other person
sit there and make their own decisions
when you're talking about the money side
i fully agree i didn't sit there and see
all those events that happened were
great i grew up in a family where my my
dad was a 99 cent store cashier i don't
know what it is to be well i've never
lived in a house i've lived in an
apartment one bedroom we don't have a
clue what it is to have money growing up
as a kid so i understand what it is to
be that person
[Music]